all right hello everybody this is
markiplier here with my brand-new let's
play of amnesia the Dark Descent just
creating a profile here I've heard this
game is quite scary so I will play it ah
here we go
yes alright no difficulty that's
reassuring loading loading that's very
creepy was that an upside down baby no
no don't forget some friends mustn't be
forgotten shadow hunting me I must hurry
hurry
I'm chef Daniel I live in London head
Mayfair Daniel lovely day fair this is
crazy
the gate don't forget I must stop him
focus my name is Daniel
it's Daniel hi Daniel yes you are
ok ah is interesting I take it this
guy's name is Daniel blue rose petals
hey hey ho hey yeah oh right to my feet
ok ok
pink goop
I can only assume it's blood
candle handle picked up a tinderbox okay
what I've seen from other videos
tinderboxes are used for lighting
candles I can't take that with me
all right then okay man he's slow is it
just me i I just sworn in other videos I
saw him moving faster that's more pink
goop
my gamer sense tells me to follow this
door what Daniel sounds scared chair aah
booyakasha huh destructible physics it's
like Red Faction up in this [ __ ]
ha ha ha all right more goop
come on yeah we go yeah I guess it pays
to explore painting very nice it's nice
to have a bit of culture in your life
ooh banners tapestries candle armor very
cool things I like it
that's
why do I hear wood beams creaking when
all the walls are stone
alright forward gabelus whoa whoa what
[ __ ]
yeah okay that was normal chandelier
shaking more pink goop uh-oh
lots of pink goop okay moocher ah what
the [ __ ]
alrighty then
that's dark tells me there's a bell ha
ha you almost had me there
I took you by the throat huh pictures oh
hey whoa what's happening ok come on
come on
ah man that's hard to get used to doors
our finest those cabinets I'm having
trouble with pictures lovely picture
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay this game has an atmosphere I can
feel it uh it's okay
alright I'm okay okay nice shirt
more pink goop following that all right
I like it
sunlight looks good I always say go
towards the light hold archives
oh the doors slam behave and we never
gives you Berkeley Square loan so London
Oh London that's where Daniels from
Mayfair haha pink goop torches oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] Oh daylight again
safe good nothing to be afraid of what
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] look that
way you two she tells me to explore
nothing why would they board up the
sunlight I'll let that [ __ ] in it is
dark in here these candles all over the
place I can't grab one okay all right
lantern cool I am amazing it pretty
clean things
right GUP rocks dark noises pitch
blackness lantern yes yes
lights lightness where's the menu
where's the options menu as if any of
you can answer me
I'll figure it out later
whoo stove oh so cold okay
who lit the stove just asking phone
dizzy you broom
yeah box tinderbox door all right
happy music I did something good
laughing for Boulder 1839 I wish I could
ask how much you remember I don't know
if there'll be anything left after I
consume this drink don't be afraid
Daniel Daniel I can't tell you why but
know this I choose to forget forget try
to find comfort and strength in that
fact there is a purpose you are my final
effort to good things right God willing
the name Alexander of Brandenburg's
Alexander's bitter anger in you if not
this will sound horrible go to the inner
sanctum
find Alexander and kill him now that's
perfectly normal is old and weak and
yours young and strong nice you are no
match for you one last thing
a shadow is following you it's a living
nightmare I'm down reality yeah I have
tried everything there is no way to
fight back Oh nuclear a bit as long as
you can redeem us both Daniel descend
into the darkness where Alexander waits
and murder him okay sounds good nor my
self Daniel thanks Daniel you have a
good one I guess why I know why it's
called amnesia now hahahaha alright oil
oil oil oil walking walking
glass funnel Oh
all right I clicked it I click dragging
yeah god I didn't move that across my
term mousepad young and strong my ass
it's got a feeble and weak with this
guide Alexander did I just figure out
the game I think I did now keep turkish
delights loved turkish delights
constantinople great place great word
great people alright this looks
promising daylight I like it
earth bat bird brother
Oh
rose petals up nope that's it whoa Oh
aleksander is it inside the car being a
manner of speaking a nerd come bring the
lab you'll bring the door finally have
you not I don't believe I have
is it connected to thee what did you
call it the inner sanctum
my most region the inner sand it lies
wealthy in fact it lies beneath the very
stone of brennenburg Renan bur ok stuff
love stuff
books books people should read more
roaches don't like them so much
pots hey pops pots go bye-bye
let's go right out the window you think
that smash destructible physics my ass
hello door big door oh hey squish squish
squish squish all right all right now oh
that's much faster
all right so rose petals slash blood
rose petals aah
rose petals okay why are there rose
petals little make it a special yeah
there we go okay yeah that's nice
squish squish squish [ __ ] I'm young
and strong
something something looks awesome all
right
yeah I'm not gonna go there the Borah
torii yes Dover Canterbury places of
import obey huh oh I should have gone
the other way shouldn't have [ __ ] it's
dark that's better ah light all right
rocks everywhere looks promising certain
get slightly rocks rocks boom what hey
oh do you - nothing I need is a whale
screaming horking my ear okay whispers
always good sign voices of no aha
yeah Oh a double boxes boxes boxes
all right right there should be more
cool right coupe right is that the thing
epithelium and one par aqua force aqua
Fortis yes I remember that from o-chem
all right I'm actually gonna have to
stop this here I will get going on part
two thank you all for watching and stick
around